I wanted to believe that Tristan could
change I wanted to trust him Khloe
Kardashian is getting real with fans
after watching that Tristan Thompson
paternity Scandal drama unfold on the
reality show I can't genuinely I cannot
believe it as it all played out on this
week's episode Coco tweeted that it was
uncomfortable to relive but praised her
famous fam for having her back I'm so
anxious I stated the other day what
Chloe how do you when did you faint
you know this all unfolded in real life
about six months ago but fans are just
now getting to see how Coco handled the
situation and they've got some opinions
one user wrote I respect y'all for being
on this positivity but F Tristan Chloe
responded with heart emojis Tristan
cheated on Chloe with a trainer named
Marilee Nichols late last year the
affair resulted in the birth of his
third child a son named Theo the whole
thing that's so sad is she wants a baby
boy and now this girl's having a baby
boy random that he sleeps with one night
second oh I was so team him
yeah we know how Khloe Kardashian's
sisters really feel about Tristan I
believe people should have multiple
chances in life I I do but it takes work
and it takes time and everyone just has
to be patient and not everyone is but
Chloe gave a little more insight into
her emotions since this isn't the first
time the NBA star has been unfaithful
when another viewer tweeted out can't
believe I forgave him like that for him
to break my girl's heart Chloe replied
with join the club hold on I'm literally
shaking
no I know after the bombshell broke the
Kardashians called a family meeting that
Chloe didn't show up to and in a teaser
for next week's episode we see her
packing up boxes which could hint at
Tristan moving out of her home since
Chloe hoped they were repairing their
old Romance
I'm not with Tristan to just float
around with Tristan I mean marriage is
the end goal but right now I still think
there's just work to be done with him
and I both and Mom Kris Jenner agrees
there's more work ahead Chloe and
Tristan have been going to couples
therapy and co-parenting their
four-year-old daughter true all Tristan
talks to me about sometimes is getting
married yeah he talks about it all the
time but I'm like he's always talking
about how much he wants to make sure
that he regains that trust that he knows
that he lost and as uncomfortable as the
episode was for Chloe Chris told ET the
raw moments are something the show is
leaning into this season I love that the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes it's
just so interesting to see it from the
inside out and really get a glimpse of
what happens and how they all balance
what they do
[Music]